in the first season of Game of Thrones
and in the first book Daenerys Targaryen
walks into a big fire and comes out
unharmed
before that she says fire cannot kill
her dragon
this has led a lot of people to believe
that Danny or all Targaryen cannot be
hurt by fire and this is not true
so a bunch of Targaryen have been burned
Danny's brother was killed with molten
gold
aerion Targaryen died after drinking
wildfire Aegon v Targaryen and Duncan
Targaryen died in a fire at the tragedy
of summerhall though we don't know
exactly what happened there and another
Targaryen who is burned is Daenerys
without spoiling anything in a chapter a
dance with dragons
Dany is burned leaving her skin pink and
tender with pale milky fluid leaking
from her cracked palms and her burns
healing Daenerys Targaryen is burned and
is not immune to fire if you need any
more proof Georgia are Martin himself
has said several times the Targaryen
czar not immune to fire quote Targaryen
czar not immune to fire capslock is the
birth of Dany's dragons was unique
magical Wanderers a miracle another
quote some fans are reading too much
into the scene in Game of Thrones where
the dragons are born it was never the
case that all Targaryen czar immune to
all fire at all times one more no
Targaryen czar immune to fire the thing
with Danny and the Dragons that was just
a one time magical event very special
and unique
the Targaryen can tolerate a bit more
heat than most ordinary people they
really like hot baths and things like
that but that doesn't mean they're
totally immune to fire so case closed
here Targaryen czar a little
heat-resistant which explains where
Danny wasn't burned by this bath or this
egg but the thing on the pyre was a
one-off and Targaryen czar not immune to
fire this has implications far plus l
equals J Jon Snow burns his hand at one
point and some people take this to mean
John can't be the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen
but since Targaryen czar not immune to
fire John can still have the blood of
the Dragon even though he was burned so
yeah just wanted to clear that up
because it's a really common
misconception if people repeat it show
them these quotes thanks for watching
you